In an earlier part of this lesson module, we saw how to build a subsystem
that takes advantage of idle memory in peer nodes on a local area network,
namely, using remote memory as a paging device, instead of the local disk. The
intuition behind that idea was the fact
that networks have gotten faster. And therefore access
to remote memory may be faster than access to an electromechanical local disk.
Continuing with this lesson, we will look
at another way to exploit remote memories,
namely, software implementation of distributed shared
memory. That is, create an operating system
abstraction that provides an illusion of shared
memory to the applications, even though the
nodes in the local area network do not physically share memory. So distributed
shared memory asks the question, if
shared memory makes life simple for application
development in a multiprocessor, can we try to provide that same abstraction
in a distributed system, and make the cluster look like a shared memory machine?